landwirt ludwig er soll aus habgier 2018
seine frau mit gülle übergossen und
damit erstickt haben so die ja fall vor
gericht er handelte laut anklage aus
angst vor einer scheidung und aus angst
sein vermögen zu verlieren und immer
wieder kam es zu streit mit seiner frau
über die versorgung der 300 schweine auf
dem hof seine drei verteidiger behaupten
jetzt die ehefrau sei zum putzen selbst
in die güllegrube gestiegen ausgerutscht
und habe dabei einen herzinfarkt
erlitten zwei prominente rechtsmediziner
sie streiten über im gericht über die
wahrheit in diesem einmaligen fall und
jörg völkerling ist an dem bauernhof wo
dieses mutmaßliche verbrechen geschehen
erste jörke wie ist die stimmung dort
bei dir im dorf tauschen auch die
dorfbewohner die argumente aus so wie
vor gericht in der tat ist dieses dorf
gespalten seit der tat vor zwei jahren
es gibt heute eine gespannte stille über
diesen ort hinter mir der bauernhof ist
verwaist die drei kinder der des
angeklagten eben woanders
und ich habe vorhin mit einem nachbarn
gesprochen der hier auch zum tatort
damals geeilt war und der mir
geschildert hat das war die ganzen jahre
immer thema am stammtisch und es ist
wohl so dass zwei drittel im ort glauben
dass der bauer die tat begangen hat
auch wenn keiner wirklich an konnte dass
dieser mann so kaltblütig sein könnte
und was glaubst du was schätzt du einen
bericht ist immer wieder über
über taten über morde über totschlag was
glaubt sowie geht dieser fall aus ja der
landwirt hat sich der unterstützung von
drei prominenten anwälten versichert die
allerdings dann nach 27 tagen
beweisaufnahme in ihrem plädoyer
zunächst mal den richtigen empfohlen
haben sie mögen mal das buch unrecht im
namen des volkes lesen und sie stünden
kurz davor ein krasses fehlurteil zu
fällen weil so viele beweisanträge von
ihnen in der vergangenheit abgelehnt
worden waren
und wer die richter und augsburg
endturnier beharrungsvermögen der wird
ahnen können dass das die denkbar
schlechteste einleitung plädoyer war
also meiner meinung nach sieht sehr viel
nach einer verurteilung aus ein ganz
düster fallen berichtet von jörg
völkerling ganz herzlichen dank